This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The long loading times. The glitchy video calls. That's your house asking for better internet. Switch to Bell Pure Fiber, Canada's most reliable internet awarded by Open Signal, from $75 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on a two-year term and auto pay credit.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。漫长的加载时间。卡顿的视频通话。那是你的房子在要求更好的网络。切换到Bell Pure Fiber，加拿大最可靠的网络，由Open Signal评选，每月75加元起。两年合约期内价格保证，并享有自动付款优惠。
Visit bell.ca for more details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Lisa? Tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all.
访问bell.ca了解更多详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。Lisa？告诉他们关于我们的新节目。我们有一个新的播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》（Don't Lie to Me）。我是Lexi Youanu。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa Di Giulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔有不同的观点，而到了50多岁的现在，我已经历了一切。
Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian. creator and host of Scam Goddess podcast. The True Crime Comedy Podcasts all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed
现在我30多岁了，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是Lacey Mosley，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员。Scam Goddess播客的创作者和主持人。这是一档关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些实施这些行为的人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周我都会邀请一位很棒的嘉宾。噢，我诈骗了
them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper, like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube. Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样，是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把聊天变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上收看我节目的完整剧集。开始在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听Scam Goddess。
Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The improvised character comedy podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up?
嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhane，Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》（Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists）播客的主持人。这是一档即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的技艺。加入我们，听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？
He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists Every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts Hey, it's Alec Baldwin
他在万圣节会眨眼。他会凑到麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。嘿，我是Alec Baldwin。
This season on my podcast, here's the thing I talk to actor Stephen Root I'm a people watcher You see that guy going down the ring though Yeah, I can use that And Open Igloo co-founder Alia Muhammad I love staying on top of what is going on in our city What is on renter's minds
本季在我的播客《这就是那件事》（Here's the Thing）中，我采访了演员Stephen Root。我是一个观察者。你看到那个家伙走下台了吗？是的，我可以用那个。还有Open Igloo的联合创始人Alia Muhammad。我喜欢掌握我们城市里正在发生的事情。租客们在想什么？
And taking all of that knowledge to build a platform that hopefully is going to make New York City better in the long run. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. to the podcast and thank you for tuning in as we break down another episode on the psychology of our 20s. So this is more of a personal episode. I guess there's been something on my mind recently or something I've been really contemplating in the last few months is that I've spent
并利用所有这些知识建立一个平台，希望从长远来看能让纽约市变得更好。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《这就是那件事》。大家好。我是Gemma Spike，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。回到播客，感谢收听我们解析《20多岁的心理学》的另一集。所以这一集更偏向个人。我想最近我心里一直有件事，或者说是我在过去几个月里一直在深思的事情，那就是我花了
my entire 20s essentially recording my life and kind of bringing you guys on this journey with me over the past five to six years. I've recorded nearly everything that has happened to me, every experience that I've had all my life lessons since I was 20, 21. And last week, you know, I had the privilege now of being able to listen back to these episodes. And I listened back to an episode I made right at the beginning in December 2021, like the first year I was making this podcast. And I recorded this episode titled The Psychology of Big Life Changes. At the time, I was just about to move to Sydney. I had just graduated university. I was heartbroken. I didn't know what I was doing. I don't, did I have a job? I don't know. I don't think I did. And there was so much advice that I wanted
我整个20多岁的时间基本上都在记录我的生活，并在过去五到六年里带着你们一起踏上这段旅程。我记录了发生在我身上的一切，我所有的经历，以及我从20、21岁以来的所有人生教训。上周，你知道，我现在有幸能够回听这些剧集。我回听了我在2021年12月刚开始制作这个播客时制作的一集。我录制了这一集，标题是《重大人生变化的心理学》。当时，我正准备搬到悉尼。我刚大学毕业。我心碎了。我不知道自己在做什么。我不知道，我有工作吗？我不知道。我想我没有。而且有太多的建议我想
to give this version of myself as I listened to this episode. And it really got me thinking, what advice would 31, 32, 33 year old Gemma have for me now during this chapter? There's just so much that doesn't become apparent until you've lived through something. And I cannot tell what 32-year-old me is thinking of this episode or any of the other episodes that I make, but I do know what I would have told my younger self at the time listening back to that episode. And as I thought about it more, I thought it would make a really interesting topic and a really interesting kind of exercise to think. If I was going to tell her, you know, five, six, seven things, what would they be? What would I scream at her?
给那个时期的自己，当我听这一集的时候。这真的让我思考，31、32、33岁的Gemma现在在这个阶段会给我什么建议？有些事情只有当你亲身经历过之后才会变得清晰。我无法判断32岁的我会如何看待这一集或我制作的任何其他剧集，但我确实知道，如果回听那一集，我会告诉年轻时的自己什么。随着我思考得越多，我觉得这会是一个非常有趣的话题，也是一个非常有趣的练习。如果我要告诉她，你知道，五、六、七件事，那会是什么？我会对她大喊什么？
And I guess also, what would I tell you guys? So somebody who's a little bit younger than me listening to this episode, who's in their early 20s about how to make the most of like this next chapter in their life. I made so many mistakes in my early 20s. And if I'm being honest, I would do about 90% of them again. And then there are some that I wouldn't do. This list contains a bit of a mixture. It contains all these things that I really think were the biggest lessons.
我想，我还会告诉你们什么？所以，对于那些比我年轻一点、正在收听这一集、处于20岁出头的人，关于如何充分利用人生的下一个阶段。我在20岁出头时犯了很多错误。老实说，我会再次犯下其中大约90%的错误。然后有一些是我不会再犯的。这个清单包含了一些混合的内容。它包含了所有我真正认为是最重要的教训。
I took from this time in my life that was just chaos and there was nothing really that I could hold on to and yet I've made it through and this like, I don't know if I would call it wisdom, this loose wisdom than I have is like kind of all I had to show for it. And I just wanted to share those lessons with you. And also I wanted to hear perhaps what you guys would say to your younger selves. If there was something that you could literally grab younger you by the shoulders and be like, just listen to me. I'm from the future. Don't do this, do that. Please think differently about this experience. What would it be? Here is my list. Feel free to share your own. Without further ado, let's get into it. Let's start off with number one. These days, you guys know, I am in like the most
我从那段混乱的人生中汲取了这些教训，当时真的没有什么我可以依靠的，然而我还是挺过来了，这种，我不知道该不该称之为智慧，这种我所拥有的零散的智慧，就是我能展示的一切。我只是想和你们分享这些教训。而且我也想听听你们可能会对年轻时的自己说什么。如果有什么事情你可以抓住年轻时的自己，摇着肩膀说：听我说。我来自未来。别做这个，做那个。请换个角度看待这次经历。那会是什么？这是我的清单。欢迎分享你们自己的。废话不多说，让我们开始吧。让我们从第一点开始。这些天，你们知道，我正处于
amazing relationship. I love my boyfriend. I kind of understand all those funny sayings people used to have in movies where they would be like, you know, he's, he's my best friend and like, I fall in love more every single day. And like, that idea of like puppy love, like I get it. And it genuinely, it's gagworthy sometimes. I'm sorry. But he truly is like just the best. He's so principal. He's so funny. He's the best person I know. Now, before this relationship, I had some shockers. If you've listened to me for a while, you'll know that. I documented them on this very podcast. And the biggest thing I took away from it. And the first thing, my 21-year-old self would be hearing from me and would be getting an earful about if I could talk to her right now
一段很棒的关系中。我爱我的男朋友。我有点理解人们在电影里常说的那些有趣的说法，比如，你知道，他是我的好朋友，而且我每天都更爱他一点。那种像小狗般的爱，我懂了。而且它确实有时让人觉得肉麻。我很抱歉。但他真的是最好的人。他非常有原则。他非常风趣。他是我认识的最好的人。现在，在这段关系之前，我遇到过一些糟糕的经历。如果你听我节目有一段时间了，你会知道这一点。我曾在本播客中记录过它们。我从中得到的最重要的东西。以及第一件事，我21岁的自己如果能听到我的话，如果我现在能和她交谈，她会听到我的唠叨
would be that the right person will never force you to compromise your friends. Period, full stop, never, ever, ever. They will never make you choose between them or me. And the right relationship should never put you in a position where you are willing to go against your deeply held loyalties and your deeply held bonds with these people for, a man, a woman, or a romantic relationship. Now, this is a lesson I learned. I learned it way too late. And it's part of those rare 10% of mistakes I would not make again and I would choose to do differently if I could and if I knew better. Now, does that mean your partner has to become best friends with all your best friends? No, like that's obviously nice. You would hope they would get along. I don't think that's necessary.
那就是对的人永远不会强迫你妥协你的朋友。句号，结束，永远，永远，永远不会。他们永远不会让你在他们和我之间做选择。对的关系永远不应该让你处于一种愿意为了一个男人、一个女人或一段浪漫关系，而违背你深信不疑的忠诚和与这些人之间深厚纽带的境地。现在，这是一个我学到的教训。我学得太晚了。这是我不会再犯的那10%的罕见错误的一部分，如果可以的话，如果我早知道，我会选择做不同的事情。现在，这是否意味着你的伴侣必须和你所有的好朋友成为好朋友？不，那当然很好。你会希望他们能相处融洽。我不认为那是必要的。
I don't think that they need to be buddy, buddy, buddy. But what they shouldn't be doing is getting in your ear and like bad. bad-mouthing these people and judging you for spending time with them or using manipulative tactics. So, you know, guilt or shame or the silent treatment to get you to prioritize them and them only. And I don't think they should be in your ear saying nasty things about these people and you certainly shouldn't be listening. I think it's also true what they say that, you know, the right person should bring out the best in you. And that's not the best if they make you or turn you against your friend. Friends, plural.
我不认为他们需要成为好哥们。但他们不应该做的是在你耳边吹风，诋毁这些人，评判你花时间和他们在一起，或者使用操纵手段。所以，你知道，内疚、羞耻或冷暴力，让你优先考虑他们，而且只考虑他们。我不认为他们应该在你耳边说这些人的坏话，而你当然也不应该听。我认为他们说的是对的，你知道，对的人应该激发你最好的一面。如果他们让你或让你反对你的朋友（复数），那不是最好的一面。
There is this idea in psychology known as the self-expansion theory of love. It was coined by Arthur and Elaine Aaron in the 1980s. And it essentially says being in love is a pathway to personal expansion, one of many pathways, but a pathway, because the best aspects of somebody else get incorporated into our own self-concept. And that results in deeper self-knowledge. Yeah, there were a lot of relationships that did the opposite. They did not expand me. They shrunk me.
心理学中有一个概念叫做爱的自我扩展理论。它是由Arthur和Elaine Aaron在20世纪80年代提出的。它本质上说，恋爱是个人扩展的途径之一，是许多途径中的一种，因为别人的最佳特质会被纳入我们自己的自我概念中。这会导致更深层的自我认知。是的，有很多关系适得其反。它们没有扩展我。它们让我萎缩了。
They made my world smaller. made me hate myself. And a lot of that came down to the influence they had on my friendships and the friendships that they caused me to lose because they wanted me to prioritize them. So Younger Jemma, listen to me right now. Run as far away from these people as you can and as soon as possible. So that's number one. That's the first thing she would she would be hearing from me about. Second, please do not try and play house with somebody before it is your time. Again, another love-based one, but why in the world did I contemplate or even think for a second that moving in with my boyfriend at 21 was going to be a good idea?
它们让我的世界变小了。让我讨厌自己。其中很多归结于他们对我的友谊的影响，以及他们导致我失去的友谊，因为他们想让我优先考虑他们。所以，年轻的Gemma，现在听我说。尽可能快地从这些人身边跑开。所以这就是第一点。这是她会从我这里听到的第一件事。第二，请不要在还没到时候之前就试图和某人过家家。同样，又是关于爱情的，但为什么我竟然会考虑，甚至想过哪怕一秒钟，在21岁时和男朋友同居是个好主意？
Why did I seriously think? Yeah, I think it's totally about time that I start settling down. This man is totally my forever. This seems comfortable. This feels like the right adult step. Why did I think that? I have a lot of grace for that version of me. I think a lot of us feel drawn towards this kind of move because
为什么我会认真地想？是的，我想是时候开始安定下来了。这个男人绝对是我的永远。这看起来很舒服。这感觉像是正确的成年人步骤。为什么我会那样想？我对那个版本的自己有很多宽容。我认为我们很多人都觉得被这种举动所吸引，因为
we kind of want to appear older than we are, especially in our early 20s, and we particularly want people around us adults to take us seriously and to see our relationships is important. So one way that we do that is that we mimic what we see or saw them doing or what we think is socially correct. And we try and force these adult moves too soon. You know, there is this deep social conditioning that your life begins when you find a partner and you move in with that person and you fall in love with that person and you are forever now and like you are this partnership. You and them are not separated. But I really do believe that the ability to have independent experiences before you make this
我们有点想表现得比实际年龄大，特别是在20岁出头的时候，我们特别希望周围的成年人认真对待我们，并认为我们的关系很重要。所以我们这样做的一种方式就是模仿我们看到或曾经看到他们做的事情，或者我们认为在社会上正确的事情。我们试图过早地强迫这些成年人的举动。你知道，有一种深刻的社会条件反射，认为你的生活始于你找到伴侣，你和那个人同居，你爱上那个人，你们现在就是永远，你们就是这种伙伴关系。你和他们没有分开。但我真的相信，在你做出这个
move is insanely, insanely important. I'm a firm believer that everything has its time and you really do have to focus and appreciate the chapter you are in right now rather than speeding towards the next milestone faster than you need to get there. If you're 21 and there is no legitimate or legal or important reason for you to move in with your partner, do not do it. Don't do it. I had a friend who moved in with somebody when she was 18. They got a mortgage and they got a cat and when they broke up, she was 26. And it's one of those typical things where, I don't know if you've noticed this, I'm sure you have, where like after two people break up, suddenly like all the problems and
举动之前，拥有独立经历的能力是极其、极其重要的。我坚信一切都有其时机，你真的必须专注于并欣赏你现在所处的阶段，而不是比你需要更快地冲向下一个里程碑。如果你21岁，并且没有合法、法律或重要的理由让你和伴侣同居，不要这样做。不要这样做。我有一个朋友在18岁时就和某人同居了。他们买了抵押贷款，养了一只猫，当他们分手时，她26岁。这是那种典型的事情之一，我不知道你是否注意到了，我相信你肯定注意到了，就像两个人分手后，突然间所有的那些问题和
difficulties they were having the entire time, like, come out into the open. And she kind of admitted, you know, I, at 18, I wasn't entirely sure I wanted to be with this person forever. But playing house and having this kind of domestic bliss relationship was something that I imagined for myself since I was a kid. And it felt fun at the time. And then soon I realized that this, I was in too deep. Another thing she mentioned to me, and this has stuck in my brain since she said it, is that, you know, it was like she had skipped an entire developmental period of her life. An entire chapter in her life was done. You know, everybody else was able to have these solo experiences and they were able to have the opportunity to live in a sharehouse by themselves with their friends and make those like really deep
他们一直以来的困难，都暴露出来了。她有点承认，你知道，我在18岁时，并不完全确定我想和这个人永远在一起。但过家家和拥有这种家庭幸福的关系是我从小就为自己想象的事情。当时觉得很有趣。然后很快我意识到，我陷得太深了。她提到的另一件事，自从她说出来后就一直在我脑海里挥之不去，那就是，你知道，就像她跳过了人生中整个发展阶段。她人生中的整个篇章都结束了。你知道，其他人能够拥有这些独自的经历，他们有机会和朋友一起住在合租房里，并与人们创造那些非常深刻的
memories with people and they, you know, lived in different states to their partner or a different city and they lived by themselves. And she was now coming into these experiences at a time when a lot of her friends had already had them and kind of felt like they had gotten what they needed from it, right? Like when they broke up, like we were 26, 27, and she was like, well, you know, a lot of my friends don't live in sharehouses anymore. A lot of them don't do these things. So if you have the opportunity to live alone, especially, if you have the opportunity
记忆，他们，你知道，住在离伴侣不同的州或不同的城市，他们独自生活。而她现在在很多朋友已经经历过这些，并且觉得他们已经从中得到了他们需要的东西的时候，才开始进入这些经历，对吧？就像当他们分手时，我们26、27岁，她说，嗯，你知道，我的很多朋友不再住在合租房里了。他们很多人不做这些事情。所以如果你有机会独自生活，特别是，如果你有机会
to live with people that you care about and friends and to have those like solo, fun, independent experiences, please, please do it. walking around IKEA, cooking dinner together, looking at apartments. It's really fun and it's really romantic and it's really cute, but like, it's not for now. And if you wait for those things, I think it makes it a lot sweeter. I also think this links to a bigger message that I would say to 21-year-old me, which is, just don't rush into adulthood earlier than you need to. Like, adulthood is going to hit you face. Like, it's common. It's not going to want to. weight, like, it's, it's going to catch up, right? You're going to get there eventually, if you have
和你在乎的人和朋友住在一起，并拥有那些独自的、有趣的、独立的经历，请，请一定要去做。在宜家走来走去，一起做晚饭，看公寓。这真的很有趣，真的很浪漫，真的很可爱，但，这不适合现在。如果你等待这些事情，我认为这会让它变得更甜蜜。我也认为这与我想对21岁的自己说的更大的信息有关，那就是，不要比你需要更早地冲进成年生活。成年生活会迎面撞上你。就像，它会来的。它不会想要等待，就像，它会赶上来的，对吧？你最终会到达那里的，如果你有
the privilege of aging and growing up, like, eventually things like moving out on your own or moving in with a partner or having this, like, kind of domestic relationship with somebody or with yourself, like, it will happen. You don't need to be doing that prematurely and kind of turning, like, the metaphorical tap off of all these other experiences that have a time and a place, often before you do those things. And it's not to say that, like, my path was the path you should take. And it's not to say that if this worked for you, that you should go back on your decision. But from myself to myself, from me at this age to me at 21, I would say, like, the thing you are contemplating, do not do it. Really enjoy this time where, yes, you are attached, but you're also
变老和成长的特权，就像，最终像独自搬出去住，或者和伴侣同居，或者和某人或你自己拥有这种家庭关系，就像，它会发生的。你不需要过早地做这些事情，并像关掉所有这些其他经历的隐喻水龙头一样，这些经历通常在你做这些事情之前都有时间和地点。这并不是说，我的道路就是你应该走的道路。这也不是说如果这对你有效，你就应该反悔你的决定。但从我对自己，从这个年龄的我到21岁的我，我会说，你正在考虑的事情，不要做。真正享受这段时间，是的，你是依附的，但你也是
unattached. Okay, let's move away from the romantic things for now and onto some more practical matters like money. What would I say to my 21-year-old self about money? If you are in your early 20s right now, all the way at the back, please listen up. Your savings account should not just be decorative. And it should not be something you just put money into and then take out again. If you are doing that regularly, so not in emergencies and not for serious need-based reasons, you are putting too much money. in your savings account. And I actually think you would be better off putting less in if that means you are better able to separate kind of like church and stay in your mind. Like if you are able to
独立的。好了，现在让我们离开浪漫的事情，谈谈一些更实际的问题，比如金钱。关于金钱，我会对21岁的自己说什么？如果你现在20岁出头，请听好了。你的储蓄账户不应该只是装饰性的。它不应该是一个你只是存钱进去然后又取出来的地方。如果你经常这样做，不是为了紧急情况，也不是为了严重的基于需求的原因，你存入储蓄账户的钱太多了。我实际上认为，如果你能更好地在心中区分开来，你会做得更好。就像如果你能
psychologically separate money that you can spend and money that you have saved and that cannot be touched, that is so much better than putting heaps of money in your savings account and then taking it out. I'm going to confess. I did not have a proper savings account until I'm going to say my early mid-20s, because I was such a financial avoidant. Financial avoidant is a term I learned from a 24 paper that was honestly incredibly eye-opening to me about our money attachment style. And it kind of laid out some of the different ways that we mentally approach and we mentally represent our relationship with money. Money has always made me anxious. I remember being so fixated on how my parents made money as a kid and whether like they were going to go bankrupt because
在心理上区分你可以花的钱和你已经存起来不能动的钱，那比把大笔钱存入储蓄账户然后又取出来要好得多。我要坦白。我直到我20多岁出头中期才有一个像样的储蓄账户，因为我是一个财务回避者。财务回避是一个我从24年的论文中学到的术语，它对我关于金钱依恋风格的认识真的非常具有启发性。它列出了一些我们在心理上接近和代表我们与金钱关系的不同方式。金钱总是让我焦虑。我记得小时候非常执着于我的父母是如何赚钱的，以及他们是否会破产，因为
I was doing all these music classes and whether, you know, things I was asking for were too expensive. Like, they never gave me a reason to worry about that. I was just like that. I was so anxious about money. I was always really anxious about, like, how did celebrities and public figures make money? Like, were they okay? What if they weren't working? How did they pay their rent? I was so invested in, like, where are they getting their money from? What's this person's net worth? Are they stressed about money? Are they surviving? Like, how do they afford these lavish lifestyles? And it honestly just felt like money was something that only ever caused stress and anxiety and deprivation. And so the easiest way to emotionally kind of take care of that was just to ignore it.
我当时在参加所有这些音乐课程，以及我要求的东西是否太贵了。他们从来没有给我任何理由担心这些。我只是那样。我对金钱非常焦虑。我总是非常焦虑，比如，名人和公众人物是如何赚钱的？他们还好吗？如果他们不工作怎么办？他们怎么付房租？我非常投入于，比如，他们从哪里得到钱？这个人的净资产是多少？他们为钱感到压力吗？他们能生存吗？他们怎么负担得起这些奢华的生活方式？老实说，这感觉就像金钱只会导致压力、焦虑和匮乏。所以情感上处理这个问题的最简单方法就是忽视它。
I would just ignore it. That has set me back. I can admit that now. If 21-year-old me had just put $25 a week into her savings account, I would have made. I would have had a 5K emergency fund by now. That's great. I would have loved to have $5,000 for a $1,000. an emergency fund. I saw an interview with, and a half of the way I think it was the other day, where she said, and I really like what she said. She said, it's not cute to be financially illiterate. And I wish I could drill that into the mind of younger me. A head in sand approach is not a healthy or helpful approach and your future self is not going to be very grateful that you've done that. So heed my warnings, get a savings account, dealer's choice, have some kind of understanding
我只会忽视它。这让我退步了。我现在可以承认这一点。如果21岁的我每周只存25美元到她的储蓄账户，我会赚到的。我现在就会有5000美元的应急基金。那太棒了。我本来会很乐意有5000美元作为1000美元的应急基金。我前几天看到一个采访，我想是另一位，她说，我真的很喜欢她说的话。她说，财务文盲并不可爱。我希望我能把这一点灌输给年轻时的自己。把头埋在沙子里的方法不是一种健康或有益的方法，你未来的自己不会因为你这样做而感到感激。所以听从我的警告，开一个储蓄账户，随你选择，对金钱及其运作方式有一些了解，你就会为生活做好准备，或者至少为你20多岁的余下时间，至少为接下来的几年做好准备。
about money and how it works and you set yourself up for life, or at least for the rest of your 20s, at least for the next couple of years. Okay, let's take a short break here. When we return, let's talk about, what have I got on this list? The risks you should take compared to those you definitely shouldn't. Oh, and my thoughts on grades. Should we worry about our grades or not? I'll be right back. long loading times. The glitchy video calls. That's your house asking for better internet.
好了，让我们在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们谈谈，我的清单上还有什么？你应该承担的风险与那些你绝对不应该承担的风险相比。哦，还有我对成绩的看法。我们应该担心我们的成绩吗？我马上回来。漫长的加载时间。卡顿的视频通话。那是你的房子在要求更好的网络。
Switch to Bell Pure Fiber, Canada's most reliable internet awarded by Open Signal from $75 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for more details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything.
切换到Bell Pure Fiber，加拿大最可靠的网络，由Open Signal评选，每月75加元起。两年合约期内价格保证，并享有自动付款优惠。访问bell.ca了解更多详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接就是一切。
Lisa, we should tell them about our new show. Oh my God, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't. me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references, occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anywhere fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today.
Lisa，我们应该告诉他们关于我们的新节目。噢，天哪，Lexi。我们有一个新的播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是Lexi Youanu。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心意相通。我是Lisa Di Giulio，年长的那位，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，偶尔有不同的观点，而到了50多岁的现在，我已经历了一切。我不会因为争吵而得到任何结果。这太疯狂了。我今天了解到了关于你的这一点。
Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business, and I've always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser. We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app. podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. I don't really care.
现在我30多岁了，作为新鞋的创始人，好品味是我的事业，我总是有话要说。如果男人对这一点诚实，世界会和平得多。我们将谈论约会、关系、美丽、变老，以及变得更聪明一点。我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是同意。因为你告诉我们你有多么迁就。显然，我会做我认为我能做的事情来战斗，但战斗是有极限的。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。《别对我撒谎》。骗子。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我真的不在乎。
Hi, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, here's the thing I'm speaking with more artists, policymakers, and performers like actor Stephen Root. I think for me to be any good or for any character actor to be any good, you've got to put enough of yourself and your empathy for people in it. I'm a people watcher. You see that guy going down to the dream? Yeah, I can use that. Open Igloo co-founder Alia Mohamed. I love staying on top of what is going on in our city, what is going on in city politics, what is on renter's minds, and taking all of that knowledge to build a platform that hopefully is going to make New York City better in the long run. And actress and singer Melissa Eriko. Partnership took on a whole other meaning when I started making my own work.
嗨，我是Alec Baldwin。本季在我的播客《这就是那件事》中，我正在与更多的艺术家、政策制定者和表演者交谈，比如演员Stephen Root。我认为对我来说，要成为任何好的演员，或者任何角色演员要成为好的演员，你必须投入足够的自我和你对人们的同理心。我是一个观察者。你看到那个家伙走下台了吗？是的，我可以用那个。Open Igloo的联合创始人Alia Mohamed。我喜欢掌握我们城市里正在发生的事情，城市政治中正在发生的事情，租客们在想什么，并利用所有这些知识建立一个平台，希望从长远来看能让纽约市变得更好。还有女演员兼歌手Melissa Eriko。当我开始创作自己的作品时，伙伴关系有了全新的意义。
It's like you with a great actress or actor. It was best to come out of your trailer, full of life, and just face another person. who's full of life and don't talk. Listen to Here's the Thing on the I Heart Radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness.
就像你和一位伟大的女演员或男演员在一起。最好从你的拖车里出来，充满活力，面对另一个充满活力的人，不要说话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《这就是那件事》。你毁了我。你不配得到幸福。
I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, we meet Carl Bryant. Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life until the messages started. You will have hell to pay. For nine months, someone infiltrated every hour,
我是Andrea Gunning。在这一季的《背叛》（Betrayal）中，我们遇到了Carl Bryant。Carl以为他过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。你会付出代价的。九个月来，有人渗透到Carl生活的每一小时、
aspect of Carl's life threatening to ruin him. Cyberstalking, swatting, extortion, impersonation. And then the text threats escalated. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. It's playing out in real life, not just on the phone. Every piece of evidence pointed to one man. But every piece of evidence was a lie. He was not going to stop unless one.
每一个方面，威胁要毁掉他。网络跟踪、虚假报警、勒索、冒充。然后短信威胁升级了。有人不会活着走出这里。这在现实生活中上演，不仅仅是在电话里。每一条证据都指向一个人。但每一条证据都是谎言。除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停止。
We stopped him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's up? I'm Tony Gonzalez. And I'm October Gonzalez. But you can call me Toby. We want you to join us on our new podcast, No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez. We get real about marriage, parenthood, sex, divorce, and all the nitty-gritty stuff we all think about, but just don't say out loud.
收听《背叛》第六季，在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，怎么了？我是Tony Gonzalez。我是October Gonzalez。但你可以叫我Toby。我们希望你加入我们的新播客《October和Tony Gonzalez的无禁忌词》（No Safe Words with October and Tony Gonzalez）。我们真实地谈论婚姻、为人父母、性、离婚以及我们都想过但只是没有大声说出来的所有细节。
I hate that job. You're probably just going to meet with some rich guy and he's going to whisk you away. and I'll never see you again. And, oh, this is awkward. Would you say a D-less actor? D? I don't even know there's such thing as D. No, no, no.
我讨厌那份工作。你可能只是会去见某个有钱人，他会把你带走，我再也见不到你了。而且，噢，这很尴尬。你会说一个D级演员吗？D？我甚至不知道有D级这种东西。不，不，不。
I mean, like, I can't even get on the C-list. Like, I'm not even an average. I'm not even passing. I'm failing. Listen to no safe words with October and Tony Gonzalez, part of My Culture Podcast Network. Available on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
我的意思是，我甚至进不了C级名单。就像我甚至不是平均水平。我甚至没有及格。我在失败。收听《October和Tony Gonzalez的无禁忌词》，My Culture播客网络的一部分。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方提供。
So these next three points are all around actually they're all around like how to create more luck and more opportunity in our lives. At 21, I had, I think, a very traditional and widely held idea of like what made somebody successful and what earned, in quotation marks, success. This was primarily in my mind, just hard work and following as specifically as possible the capital P plan. The capital P plan is one that you've probably followed as well, or at least you've been informed, of, which sounds something like this. High school, study hard, do as many extracurriculars as possible. University or college, get into a good one, get into a good college, continue to study hard,
所以接下来的这三点都是关于，实际上它们都是关于如何在我们生活中创造更多的运气和更多的机会。在21岁时，我想，我有一个非常传统且被广泛持有的想法，关于什么使一个人成功，以及什么赢得了，加引号的，成功。这主要在我脑海中，只是努力工作并尽可能具体地遵循大写P计划。大写P计划是你可能也遵循过的，或者至少你被告知过的，听起来像这样。高中，努力学习，尽可能多地参加课外活动。大学或学院，进入一所好的，进入一所好的大学，继续努力学习，
internships, networking, summers working, post-college, get a prestigious job, continue to work hard, 12 hours a day, move up the corporate ladder, this is your guarantee that you're going to be happy. I'm going to be honest, that worked for me for a while, but there is something beyond this system that I think is much more helpful and much more fulfilling, and that is a pure audacity and be a strive to fail approach. 21-year-old me had a great plan. She had a good plan. She was doing okay. But what really shifted things in my life was realizing how many people who were much less qualified than me probably worked a lot less hard than me, definitely spent less time planning and ruminating achieved things that I really wanted for myself because they just asked for them
实习，社交，暑期工作，大学毕业后，获得一份有声望的工作，继续努力工作，每天12小时，在公司阶梯上往上爬，这是你保证会快乐的。我要诚实，这在一段时间内对我有效，但在这个系统之外还有一些东西，我认为更有帮助，更令人满足，那就是纯粹的胆量和勇于失败的方法。21岁的我有一个伟大的计划。她有一个好的计划。她做得还可以。但真正改变我生活的是意识到有多少比我资格少得多的人，可能比我努力工作少得多的人，绝对花更少的时间计划和沉思，却实现了我真正想要的东西，因为他们只是要求了它们，
and they just did stuff. They didn't just sit around planning. They just like actually went after it. It should be your mission if you were in your 20s, early 20s, to appreciate like the remarkable gift of being able to fail continuously for years and years and years and years and years and and still end up exactly where you need to be. Like that is the gift of our early 20s. And that's the worst case scenario. The worst case scenario is that you fail and you fail and you fail and then maybe you win. But the majority of the time that, like, you actually just win a lot earlier and a lot more than you think. A lot of the time trying does not result in failure. It actually results in, you know, some degree of success, some essential pivot or connection or opportunity.
而且他们只是做了事情。他们没有只是坐在那里计划。他们只是，就像，真正去追求它。如果你在20多岁，20岁出头，你的使命应该是欣赏那种能够连续几年、几年、几年、几年、几年不断失败，却依然能最终到达你需要到达的地方的非凡天赋。就像那是我们20岁出头的礼物。而且那是最坏的情况。最坏的情况是你失败了，你失败了，你失败了，然后也许你赢了。但大多数时候，就像，你实际上只是赢得很早，而且比你想象的要多得多。很多时候尝试并不会导致失败。它实际上导致了，你知道，某种程度的成功，某种本质的转折或联系或机会。
So number one, something I'd say to my 21-year-old self, shoot all your shots. Do not just, like, leave the ball sitting there. And number two, trust in the serendipity of things. Younger me was so terrified and worried about how her life was going to turn out because she only had one formula. She only had the capital P plan. And she only had like one narrow vision of like what a life that worked out would look like. What I wish she would knew was that a lot of life is a surprise and a lot of success and fulfillment is an accident. And also a lot of those accidents take a while to come to fruition. Like a lot of those serendipitous moments, you only realize a little while later. For example, when I was in like 19, I took a random
所以第一点，我想对21岁的自己说，尝试你所有的机会。不要只是，就像，让球留在那里。第二点，相信事物的机缘巧合。年轻时的我非常害怕和担心她的生活会变成什么样，因为她只有一个公式。她只有大写P计划。而且她只有一种狭隘的愿景，关于一个成功的生活会是什么样子。我希望她知道的是，生活很多时候是一个惊喜，很多成功和满足感是一个意外。而且很多那些意外需要一段时间才能实现。就像很多那些机缘巧合的时刻，你只有在稍后一点才意识到。例如，当我在19岁左右时，我选修了一门随机的
international political economy elective where in that course you had to make a podcast. That was an assignment, make a podcast about a political event. Had I not done that, a year or, like, no, two years later, I wouldn't have known how to do any editing or recording or scripting that allowed me to do what I'm doing now. I don't even remember what that first podcast was about, but it like serendipitously set me up for the career that I now have. And that's insane to me sometimes to think about it. Another example is a random person I met at a party when I was 18 was a big reason why I moved to London seven years later. And if I hadn't met that person, would I have made that move? Maybe not. Probably not. To be honest,
国际政治经济学选修课，在那门课程中你必须制作一个播客。那是一个作业，制作一个关于政治事件的播客。如果我没有那样做，一年后，或者，就像，不，两年后，我就不会知道如何进行任何编辑或录制或编写脚本，这让我能够做我现在正在做的事情。我甚至不记得第一个播客是关于什么的，但它机缘巧合地为我现在拥有的职业生涯做好了准备。这对我来说有时觉得很疯狂。另一个例子是，我在18岁时在派对上遇到的一个随机的人，是我七年后搬到伦敦的一个重要原因。如果我没有遇到那个人，我会做出那个举动吗？也许不会。可能不会。老实说，
One more example here, because I really do believe in the power of serendipity. I had this discussion with somebody months ago about how we need to make research more accessible, and we were talking about it. That became my study of the week series. It's like huge on substack. Even like I changed my major to psychology at the last minute when I was like 18. And that wouldn't have happened if I hadn't have had one specific class that I loved. like all these things serendipity has helped me in equal measure to hard work and one of the biggest
这里再举一个例子，因为我真的相信机缘巧合的力量。几个月前我和某人讨论过我们需要如何让研究更容易获取，我们谈论了它。那成为了我的每周研究系列。它在Substack上非常火。甚至像我最后一刻把专业改为心理学，当我18岁时。如果我没有上过一门我喜欢的特定课程，那也不会发生。就像所有这些事情，机缘巧合在同等程度上帮助了我，就像努力工作一样，而增加你遇到机缘巧合的可能性最大的
ways to increase your likelihood of encountering serendipity is to simply just like do more things and to get outside more and to talk to more people and to increase your surface area for that serendipity and that luck to kind of hit you okay so this is point number five I think we're up to number five by this stage I'm hoping younger jemma was taking notes but she probably wasn't However, younger Gemma, stop spending all your Thursday and Friday nights inside and drinking. Allow yourself to be inconvenience by people and inconvenience by plans and get outside of your house. Your life is not going to change or evolve or do anything if you don't move and you don't get out of your home. my point above about talking to more people in particular is really important here.
方法之一就是简单地，就像，做更多的事情，多出去走走，多和人交谈，增加你遇到那种机缘巧合和运气的表面积。好了，这是第五点，我想我们到了第五点，我希望年轻的Gemma在做笔记，但她可能没有。然而，年轻的Gemma，停止把所有的周四和周五晚上都花在室内和喝酒上。允许自己被人们打扰，被计划打扰，走出你的房子。如果你不走动，不走出你的家，你的生活就不会改变或进化或做任何事情。我上面关于多和人交谈的观点在这里特别重要。
And it's essentially a less corporate way of saying your network is what makes you. And the only way to create a network is to not be at home. You know, when people would say to me when I was younger, like, your network is the most important thing for your career. If I'm being honest, I was like, I don't understand that and I don't really care. But over time, I've really witnessed repeatedly how the greatest catalyst for my job, for my life, life, for my personal life, for my career, have not been job applications. It hasn't been anything formal. The biggest pivots in my life have been relationships. For example, people who have spoken highly of me in rooms that I'm not in, or who've heard about an opportunity and thought,
这本质上是一种不那么企业化的说法，即你的网络成就了你。而创造网络的唯一方法就是不要待在家里。你知道，当我年轻时人们对我说，就像，你的网络是你职业生涯中最重要的事情。如果我诚实的话，我会说，我不明白，我也不在乎。但随着时间的推移，我真的反复见证了我的工作、我的生活、我的个人生活、我的职业生涯的最大催化剂，不是工作申请。它不是任何正式的东西。我生命中的最大转折是人际关系。例如，在我不存在的房间里高度评价我的人，或者听说了一个机会并认为，
Gemma might be good for that and told me. Literally, last month, I had a chance to do a live podcast recording, like, in the tallest building in London, because somebody pulled out last minute, And the person who was hosting this event, I just happened to have been speaking to the week before. We had a relationship. That's literally it. That opportunity was never going to be advertised. There was not going to be any formal procedure for that. Having those relationships because I got out of my home is what made that happen.
Gemma可能适合那个，并告诉了我。就在上个月，我有机会在伦敦最高的建筑里进行现场播客录制，因为有人最后一刻退出了，而主持这个活动的人，我刚好在前一周和她交谈过。我们有关系。就是这样。那个机会永远不会被广告宣传。不会有任何正式的程序。拥有这些关系，因为我走出了家门，才使这一切成为可能。
And I don't want this to come across as bragging, especially like being like, I was doing this cool thing. But I also want it to come off as like evidence. Like this is, I want this to be a convincing argument for why you should be doing the following things. when you get invited to things, go. Even if you leave after 30 minutes, go. If there was some kind of live show, networking event, talk, anything you're interested in, be there. Go to that thing. Do not expect your life to change from your bedroom, as I truly believed it could at that age.
我不希望这听起来像是在吹牛，特别是像，我正在做这件很酷的事情。但我也希望它听起来像证据。就像这是，我希望这是一个令人信服的论点，说明为什么你应该做以下事情。当你被邀请参加事情时，去。即使你30分钟后离开，去。如果有某种现场表演、社交活动、演讲，任何你感兴趣的事情，去那里。去参加那件事。不要指望你的生活会从你的卧室里改变，就像我在那个年龄真正相信的那样。
At 21, I wasn't doing nearly enough, and I feel like I would have had more opportunities if I had. Additionally, and I'm going to treat this as a separate point, do not let drinking be your only form of socialization. I was saying this to a friend the other day. What was I saying? I basically was saying to them, going out for drinks is so boring. It's so boring. Like you sit around, you spend $40. And unless like you're going somewhere, you just rehash the same stories. And somebody's probably heard the story before. And somebody, the person telling it's already lived the story, especially in my early 20s, like every activity had to have some kind of alcohol involved. And it's just a social crutch. And it actually doesn't help you create as many memories.
21岁时，我做得远远不够，我觉得如果我当时做得更多，会有更多的机会。此外——我要把这一点单独提出来——不要让喝酒成为你唯一的社交方式。前几天我还在跟一个朋友说这个。我当时在说什么来着？我基本上是在跟他们说，出去喝酒太无聊了。真的太无聊了。就像你坐在那儿，花了40美元。除非你要去什么特别的地方，否则你只是在重复讲同样的故事。而且可能有人已经听过这个故事了。讲故事的人自己也已经经历过那个故事了，尤其是在我20岁出头的时候，好像每项活动都必须涉及某种酒精。这只是一种社交拐杖。而且它实际上并不能帮你创造更多的回忆。
So take a break from it for a second, give your liver a break for starters for your health, and actually engage with people in a way that builds shared experiences. Because a lot of my stories back then started with like, oh, well, we were drunk that one night or like, remember that time we went and did this and like, remember when we were drunk doing that? Remember when we were drinking at home? Don't get me wrong. I love a wine.
所以，暂时休息一下吧，为了你的健康，先让你的肝脏休息一下，真正地以一种能建立共同经历的方式与人交往。因为我那时候的很多故事都是以“哦，那天晚上我们喝醉了”或者“还记得我们去做了那个的时候吗，还记得我们喝醉了做那件事的时候吗？还记得我们在家喝酒的时候吗？”开头。别误会，我喜欢喝葡萄酒。
I love a gossip. But did I like it enough to be doing it four to five times a week and then actually not even going anywhere? probably not and I wished that at 21 I'd gone outside I'd explored I'd experienced more I think I also wish I'd get on into nature and gotten a few more hobbies that didn't just revolve around drinking and I will give myself some grace like it was lockdown when this was happening so there wasn't as much to be done I probably should have mentioned that at the beginning but even so like where I was living we didn't have a serious lockdown there was heaps of stuff that I could have been doing like I could
我喜欢八卦。但我真的喜欢到每周四五次，而且实际上哪儿也没去吗？可能没有。我希望21岁时我能走出去，去探索，去体验更多。我想我也希望我能走进大自然，培养一些不仅仅围绕着喝酒的爱好。我会对自己宽容一点，毕竟这发生的时候正处于封锁期间，所以能做的事情不多。我本来应该在开头就提到这一点，但即便如此，我住的地方并没有严格的封锁，我本来可以做很多事情，比如我可以
have been out in nature. I could have been doing so much fun stuff. And I do think it's a ride of passage in our early 20s for drinking to be this problem or at least this thing that we're very fixated on. 21 year old me, give it a rest. Give it a little rest for a while. I want to return to an earlier point here for a second. I've got my little notes up with my points. Before we get into the final break, I spoke earlier about this idea of the capital P. plan. And one of the biggest components of that plan, as you may have noticed, was study. Now, a little bit later, we're going to dive into some of the advice that you, the listeners, would have for your 21-year-old selves and people who were in their early 20s. We're going to get to that.
去大自然中。我本来可以做很多有趣的事情。我确实认为，在20岁出头时，把喝酒当成一个问题，或者至少是我们非常执着的一件事，是一种成人礼。21岁的我，歇一歇吧。稍微休息一会儿。我想回到之前提到的一个点。我把我的要点写在小笔记上了。在进入最后一次休息之前，我之前谈到了那个大写的“计划”的概念。正如你可能注意到的，那个计划中最大的组成部分之一就是学习。现在，稍后我们将深入探讨你们这些听众给21岁的自己以及20岁出头的人的一些建议。我们马上就会讲到。
But one thing that came up a lot in which was quite interesting was this split. Half of the time people mentioned grades. They said, care less about grades. And the other half of the time, people said care more and invest more. I'm going to give my opinion. If younger me was to ask current me, who should I side with? I'm going to side with teen care less. My life at 21 was home, study, study, study, study, study, drink with friends, sleep, study, study, study, home, drink with friends. And study some more. And it's hard at that age to not be preoccupied with grades because it feels like one of life's few guaranteed promises. Like, there seems to be a direct correlate between input and output.
但其中一个出现频率很高且非常有趣的点是这种分歧。一半的人提到了成绩。他们说，少关心成绩。而另一半人则说，要多关心，多投入。我要给出我的看法。如果年轻的我问现在的我，我该站在哪一边？我会站在“少关心”这一边。我21岁时的生活就是：回家、学习、学习、学习、学习、学习、和朋友喝酒、睡觉、学习、学习、学习、回家、和朋友喝酒。然后再多学一点。在这个年纪，不被成绩所困扰是很难的，因为它感觉像是生活中为数不多的有保证的承诺之一。就像投入和产出之间似乎有直接的关联。
Like, it is a safe investment to emphasize study. If you get good grades, you're at least going to, like, something's going to come to you. There's going to be some kind of reward. Now, these days, can I tell you in all seriousness, like, what good grades got me? Like, it kind of got me very little. Like, I can't remember the last time somebody asked to see my GPA. I couldn't tell you a single score that I received on an exam or an essay, none of it. You know, I was in a grad cohort of people much smarter than me who had a lot more fun than I had
就像强调学习是一项安全的投资。如果你成绩好，你至少会……会有什么东西回报你。会有某种奖励。现在，这些天，我能严肃地告诉你，好成绩给我带来了什么吗？它几乎没给我带来什么。我不记得上次有人要求看我的GPA是什么时候了。我也说不出我在考试或论文中得到的任何一个分数，一点都不记得。你知道，我在一个研究生群体里，里面的人比我聪明得多，他们比我玩得开心得多，
and had gotten much worse grades and yet here we were in the same place. Like, grades unlock very specific opportunities. I understand that. So if you're trying to get into med school or law school or a school, or a specific specific program, feel free to disregard this. However, in general, a good grade I have learned can be supplemented by life experience and it can be supplemented by that aforementioned, like audacity or entrepreneurial spirit in my mind, or just experiences. Additionally, like say you didn't get good grades and you feel like that's limited your opportunities and you feel like
而且成绩比我差得多，但我们却处在同一个位置。成绩确实能开启非常特定的机会。我明白这一点。所以如果你正试图进入医学院、法学院或某个特定的项目，请随意忽略这一点。然而，总的来说，我学到的是，好成绩可以由生活经验来补充，在我看来，它也可以由前面提到的那种胆识或创业精神，或者仅仅是经历来补充。此外，假设你没有取得好成绩，你觉得这限制了你的机会，你觉得
it's held you back, very few people end their working life with the job that they began with. The memory of grades and the memory of GPAs and test scores, you will realize fades extremely quickly when you enter the workplace. And I think that's really important to inform you of, especially if you're still in uni or school and you're quite fixated on it or you're feeling very demoralized by a bad term or a bad semester. I'm going to give you a Gemsberg psychology of your 20s promise right here right now. Your future boss will not care about what you're going to. grades are if you work hard and you're nice to work with and you show some enthusiasm. Very quickly, it becomes something nobody talks about. Okay. I feel like I've done, I think I've done
它阻碍了你，很少有人在职业生涯结束时从事的是他们开始时那份工作。你会意识到，对成绩、GPA和考试分数的记忆在你进入职场后会消失得非常快。我认为这一点非常重要，需要告诉你，特别是如果你还在上大学或学校，并且对此非常执着，或者因为一个糟糕的学期而感到非常沮丧。我现在就要给你一个关于20岁心理学的承诺。如果你努力工作，与人相处融洽，并表现出热情，你未来的老板根本不会在乎你的成绩是什么。很快，这就会变成没人谈论的事情。好了。我觉得我已经完成了，我想我已经完成了
six lessons, six things that I would really tell my younger self. I wanted to hear from you guys. What did you have to say? What were your points about this? And I collected some of them, put them into a little list. Let's talk about them after this short break. The long loading times. The glitchy video calls. That's your house asking for better internet. Switch to Bell Pure Fiber, Canada's most reliable internet awarded by Open Signal from $75 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on a two-year term and auto pay credit.
六个课程，六件我真的想告诉年轻自己的事情。我想听听你们的看法。你们对此有什么观点？我收集了一些，把它们列成了一个小清单。休息片刻后我们来谈谈这些。加载时间长。视频通话卡顿。那是你的房子在要求更好的网络。切换到贝尔纯光纤（Bell Pure Fiber），这是由Open Signal评选的加拿大最可靠的网络，每月75美元起。两年合约期内价格保证，并有自动付款优惠。
Visit bell.ca for more details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Lisa? We should tell them about our new show. Oh my God, Lexi. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Yuwano. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references,
访问bell.ca了解更多详情并查询覆盖范围。贝尔，连接就是一切。丽莎？我们应该告诉他们我们的新节目。天哪，莱克西。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》（Don't Lie to Me）。我是莱克西·尤瓦诺。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却贴得很近。我是丽莎·迪朱利奥，那个年长的人，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，
occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. I'm not going to get anywhere fighting. That is wild. I learned that about you today. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste is my business. And I've always Always got something to say. If men were just honest about this, there would be so much more peace in the world. We're going to talk about dating, relationships, beauty, getting older, and a little wiser.
偶尔有不同的观点，而在我50多岁的现在，我已经经历了一切。我不会在争吵中得到任何结果。那太疯狂了。我今天才了解到你这一点。现在我30多岁了，作为新鞋品牌的创始人，好品味是我的生意。而且我总是有话要说。如果男人们能对此诚实一点，世界会和平得多。我们将谈论约会、人际关系、美妆、变老，以及变得更睿智一点。
We're best friends, but we don't always agree. Because you told us how accommodating you are. Obviously, I would do what I think I could do to fight the fight, but there's only so much fight I can fight. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me.
我们是最好的朋友，但我们并不总是意见一致。因为你告诉我们你有多迁就别人。显然，我会尽我所能去抗争，但我能抗争的程度是有限的。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。
Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Liar. Listen on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. I don't really care. Hi, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast,
别对我撒谎。别对我撒谎。骗子。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我真的不在乎。嗨，我是亚历克·鲍德温。本季在我的播客上，
here's the thing I'm speaking with more artists, policymakers, and performers like actor Stephen Root. I think for me to be any good or for any character act to be any good, you've got to put enough of yourself and your empathy for people in it. I'm a people watcher. You see that guy going down the dream and go,
《这就是事实》（Here's the Thing），我正在与更多的艺术家、政策制定者和表演者交谈，比如演员斯蒂芬·鲁特。我想对我来说，要表现出色，或者任何角色表演要出色，你必须投入足够的自我和你对他人的同理心。我是一个观察者。你看到那个人走在街上，然后想，
yeah, I can use that. Open Igloo co-founder, Alia Muhammad. I love staying on top of what is going on in our city, what is going on in city politics, what is on renter's minds, and taking all of that knowledge to build a platform that hopefully is going to make New York City better in the long run. And actress and singer Melissa Eriko. Partnership took on a whole other meaning when I started making my own work. It's like you with a great actress or actor. It was best to come out of your trailer, full of life, and just face another person who's full of. of life and don't talk.
是的，我可以利用这一点。Open Igloo联合创始人阿莉亚·穆罕默德。我喜欢掌握我们城市正在发生的事情，城市政治中正在发生的事情，租客们在想什么，并利用所有这些知识建立一个平台，希望从长远来看能让纽约市变得更好。还有女演员兼歌手梅丽莎·埃里科。当我开始制作自己的作品时，合作有了全新的意义。就像你和一个伟大的女演员或男演员在一起。最好是从你的拖车里走出来，充满活力，面对另一个充满活力的人，不要说话。
Listen to Here's the Thing on the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. You broke me. You do not deserve happiness. I'm Andrea Gunning. On this season of betrayal, we meet Carl Bryant. Carl thought he was living a normal, drama-free life until the messages started. You will have hell to pay.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《这就是事实》。你毁了我。你不配拥有幸福。我是安德里亚·甘宁。在这一季的《背叛》（Betrayal）中，我们遇到了卡尔·布莱恩特。卡尔以为他过着正常、没有戏剧性的生活，直到那些信息开始出现。你会付出代价的。
For nine months, someone infiltrated every aspect. of Carl's life threatening to ruin him. Cyberstalking, swatting, extortion, impersonation. And then the text threats escalated. Someone's not going to make it out of this alive. It's playing out in real life, not just on the phone. Every piece of evidence pointed to one man. But every piece of evidence was a lie.
九个月来，有人渗透到卡尔生活的方方面面，威胁要毁掉他。网络跟踪、假报警、勒索、冒充。然后短信威胁升级了。有人不会活着离开这里。这在现实生活中上演，不仅仅是在手机上。每一条证据都指向一个人。但每一条证据都是谎言。
He was not going to stop unless we stopped. him. Listen to Betrayal Season 6 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You're not incurable. You're not broken. You're having a normal human experience, and we have a solution for that. And that solution is our show Free Therapy. I'm Ben.
除非我们阻止他，否则他不会停手。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《背叛》第六季。你不是不可治愈的。你没有崩溃。你正在经历一种正常的人类体验，我们对此有一个解决方案。那个解决方案就是我们的节目《免费治疗》（Free Therapy）。我是本。
And I'm Kevin. And we think everyone could use a little bit of therapy, including us. Absolutely. That's why each week, we sit down with a different therapist to talk about the things we're all dealing. If you're trying to get rid of anxiety, you're actually fueling more anxiety. We talk to some of the leading therapists in the country about all of life's headaches, work, family dynamics, and of course, dating in relationships. Everyone chooses a different set of problems, challenges, flaws.
我是凯文。我们认为每个人都可以接受一点治疗，包括我们。绝对是这样。这就是为什么每周我们都会坐下来与不同的治疗师交谈，讨论我们都在处理的事情。如果你试图摆脱焦虑，你实际上是在助长更多的焦虑。我们与国内一些顶尖的治疗师谈论生活中的所有头痛事、工作、家庭动态，当然还有约会和人际关系。每个人都会选择一套不同的问题、挑战和缺陷。
You have to figure out which set of problems you're willing to work with. So listen to Free Therapy with Ben and Kevin on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because therapy is expensive, but our podcast is free. So as I said, in thinking about this episode, I knew I also wanted to hear from you guys. Like, I am just one person. These are the lessons that I'd impress on my younger self.
你必须弄清楚你愿意处理哪一套问题。所以请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听本和凯文的《免费治疗》。因为治疗很贵，但我们的播客是免费的。所以正如我所说，在思考这一集时，我知道我也想听听你们的看法。我只是一个人。这些是我会强加给年轻自己的教训。
And they may not be the lessons that your younger self needed or would resonate with. Like, these lessons, these things that I would scream at her. are based on a very narrow life perspective, i.e. the life of one person. So I wanted to hear your collective wisdom as well. We had over a thousand responses, a lot of responses. And it was difficult to kind of siphon them down. But here is a curated selection of my favorites. What would you, the listeners, scream, shout, yell, grab, impress on your younger selves. number one, don't hang out with people you don't want to be like. I will say there is psychological evidence for this one. Behavioral and emotional contagion is a real thing, a very real phenomena,
它们可能不是你年轻时所需要的，或者无法引起你的共鸣。这些教训，这些我会对她大喊大叫的事情，是基于一个非常狭隘的生活视角，即一个人的生活。所以我也想听听你们的集体智慧。我们收到了超过一千条回复，很多回复。要把它们筛选出来很困难。但这里是我最喜欢的一些精选。你们这些听众会对着年轻的自己尖叫、大喊、咆哮、抓住并强调什么？第一，不要和那些你不想成为的人混在一起。我会说这有心理学依据。行为和情绪传染是一种真实存在的东西，一种非常真实的现象，
and the attitudes and personalities of those around you is going to have an effect on your own attitude and personality. So if you don't admire and respect the people in your life and the people in your social circles, break out of that circle, run far away, you will make new friends. Okay, number two, I love this one. Don't let doctors dismiss your symptoms. I actually think I probably should have put this one on my list. There were so many things that were going wrong or not, didn't feel right in my body at 21 and I would go to the doctor and they would just say, you're fine, it's just anxiety. And now that I'm older, they have actually turned into very serious things that like now need treatment and now need medication. And
你周围人的态度和个性会对你自己的态度和个性产生影响。所以如果你不钦佩和尊重你生活中的人以及你社交圈里的人，那就跳出那个圈子，跑得远远的，你会交到新朋友的。好了，第二，我喜欢这个。不要让医生忽视你的症状。我其实觉得我可能应该把这一条加到我的清单上。21岁时，我的身体里有很多事情出了问题，或者感觉不对劲，我会去看医生，他们只会说，你很好，这只是焦虑。现在我老了，它们实际上已经变成了非常严重的问题，现在需要治疗，现在需要药物。而且
I get so mad thinking about those doctors who could have just listened to me. And I also get kind of sad for my younger self who didn't just like speak up for herself and didn't say pay attention to me or didn't ask for a referral or another opinion. If you're 21 and you're like something might not be right, I can, I don't feel good in my body or my mind or I just know that something's off. advocate for yourself, push, push your doctors. You are paying for that service. It is a service that your, maybe your taxes pay for, or you are paying for out of pocket. It is there to serve you and to make you well. So if it's not making you well because you're still there, stressed,
想到那些本可以听我说话的医生，我就很生气。我也为那个没有为自己挺身而出，没有说“请关注我”，或者没有要求转诊或寻求第二意见的年轻自己感到难过。如果你21岁，你觉得有些事情可能不对劲，我……我觉得我的身体或心理感觉不好，或者我只是知道有什么不对劲。为自己辩护，推动，推动你的医生。你在为那项服务付费。那是你的税收可能支付的服务，或者你是自掏腰包支付的。它是为了服务你并让你康复而存在的。所以如果它没有让你康复，因为你仍然在那里，感到压力，
anxious, not feeling good, it is your right to keep pushing and to get an answer. Even if that answer is actually, no, everything is all right. The peace of mind that it will give you will just be so, so valuable. Okay, number three, this one I love, try not to grow up, get a degree in full-time work so quickly, take a gap year, take two, take your time. This next one was funny because these two things came up right next to each other. The first one was date him, the other one was don't date him, which I think was funny. This one also good, you are not making a life-changing decision when you choose a college or choose a major. This person said, 21-year-old me has to understand that paths unexpectedly converge. I 100% agree with that. Go dancing was another one, that somebody
焦虑，感觉不好，你有权继续推动并得到一个答案。即使那个答案实际上是“不，一切都很好”。它带给你的那种内心的平静将是非常、非常有价值的。好了，第三，我喜欢这个，尽量不要那么快长大，去拿学位，去全职工作，休个间隔年，休两个，慢慢来。接下来这个很有趣，因为这两件事是紧挨着出现的。第一个是“和他约会”，另一个是“不要和他约会”，我觉得这很有趣。这个也很好，当你选择大学或专业时，你并不是在做一个改变人生的决定。这个人说，21岁的我必须明白，道路会出人意料地汇合。我100%同意这一点。去跳舞是另一个，有人
would scream at their younger self. Let your friends make their own mistakes. That's a big sign of emotional maturity when you can let your friends do that. Don't get a boob job. Don't get a boob job. That's what they would say to their younger self. I haven't gotten a boob job, so I don't know if I could relate to one, but take that as you will. Be careful with credit cards. Yes, be careful with credit cards. That goes hand in hand with the savings one. If you don't have the financial literacy to save or to budget or to do any of those things, like if you don't just have the skills or even the income yet, do not get a credit card, it will, it spells danger. This was another funny one. Again, literally these were side by side. When I tell you, I was reading through and it was like, this one came up
会对年轻的自己尖叫。让你的朋友犯他们自己的错误。当你能让朋友这样做时，这是一个情感成熟的重大标志。不要去做隆胸手术。不要去做隆胸手术。这就是他们会对自己年轻时说的话。我没有做过隆胸手术，所以我不知道我是否能感同身受，但随你怎么想吧。小心信用卡。是的，小心信用卡。这与储蓄那条相辅相成。如果你还没有储蓄、预算或做任何这些事情的金融素养，比如如果你还没有掌握这些技能，甚至还没有收入，就不要办信用卡，它……它意味着危险。这是另一个有趣的。同样，这些真的是并列的。当我告诉你时，我读着读着，就像这一条出现了，
and then the second one came up right afterwards. They said, date the 28-year-old. That's what I would tell my 21-year-old self. And the other one said, don't date the 28-year-old from work, which I thought was funny. This was a theme, actually. This was a theme in itself. Time and time again, I would see this thing where one person would be like, buy stocks instead of dinner at the club.
然后第二条紧接着出现了。他们说，和28岁的人约会。这就是我会告诉21岁的自己的话。而另一条说，不要和工作中的28岁的人约会，我觉得这很有趣。这其实是一个主题。这本身就是一个主题。一次又一次，我会看到这种情况，一个人会说，买股票而不是在俱乐部吃晚餐。
And then somebody else would be like, who cares about being financially responsible? Go and have a drink. somebody would be like, I would tell my 21-year-old self to like, yeah, marry their childhood sweetheart. And then somebody else would be like, don't marry your childhood sweetheart. The contradictions and the differing opinions contained here, I think actually create a beautiful summary and a beautiful ending to this episode. And it actually kind of leads into the final thing I would say to 21-year-old me. And it's, mine actually undermine everything else I've said.
然后另一个人会说，谁在乎财务责任？去喝一杯吧。有人会说，我会告诉21岁的自己，去……是的，嫁给青梅竹马。然后另一个人会说，不要嫁给你的青梅竹马。这里包含的矛盾和不同的观点，我认为实际上为这一集创造了一个美丽的总结和一个美丽的结尾。它实际上有点引出了我要对21岁的自己说的最后一件事。而且，我的观点实际上削弱了我所说的一切。
So I'm sorry, I've like brought you here under a row of a real. ruse and I'm about to completely contradict a lot of my advice. But the final thing I would imprint on my younger self, somebody else's advice may be helpful, but it's not everything. You don't have to believe or follow or abide by what somebody else suggests just because they think it's what's best for you or just because it worked for them. I think the scariest thing about our 20s is that they are defined by a lack of definition, right? Nothing feels known. And that creates a desire to find clarity or certainty in any corner that we can. That is simply a human urge.
所以我很抱歉，我好像把你带到了一个真正的……诡计之下，我正要完全反驳我的很多建议。但我会印在年轻自己脑海里的最后一件事是，别人的建议可能有帮助，但它不是一切。你不必相信、遵循或遵守别人建议的内容，仅仅因为他们认为这对你最好，或者仅仅因为这对他们有效。我认为我们20多岁时最可怕的事情是，它们是由缺乏定义来定义的，对吧？没有什么感觉是已知的。这产生了一种在任何角落寻找清晰或确定性的渴望。这仅仅是一种人类的冲动。
It's a human urge to insert any kind of structure or rulebook or guidelines where sometimes one just simply doesn't exist. And in that desire for clarity, we're sometimes imprisoned by this constant rumination and this constant thought of, am I making the right choices? Am I making the right mistakes? what if like how do I make my life turn out perfectly it it just will it just will like I've been in such a strange state recently as I contemplate my next chapter and my 30s and what comes next and am I going to make the psychology of your 30s and it is a similar state to how I felt at 21 and what
插入任何结构、规则手册或指导方针是一种人类的冲动，而有时这些东西根本不存在。在那种对清晰的渴望中，我们有时会被这种不断的反刍和不断的思考所囚禁，比如：我做出了正确的选择吗？我犯了正确的错误吗？如果……我该如何让我的生活变得完美？它会……它会……我最近处于一种非常奇怪的状态，因为我正在思考我的下一个篇章和我的30多岁，以及接下来会发生什么，我是否要制作《30多岁的心理学》，这和我21岁时的感觉很相似，而我
I continue to remind myself is like things never turned out exactly as planned they turned out very differently, they also turned out so much better. And even when they didn't turn out so much better, they turned out okay. Every single mistake, every single thing, moment led to this perfect, and it's not even a finale. It sounds like I'm at the end, but it's not a finale. It led to these perfect circumstances that I wouldn't change. And there were a lot of things that got me to this place, terrible boyfriends, terrible grades, really big friendshipful outs where like I was the one in the wrong and I still feel guilty about it and bad, bad financial decisions. Let me tell you that. I've made bad financial choices. Would I make them again? No. But how can I say that if I didn't
继续提醒自己的是，事情从来没有完全按计划进行，它们的结果非常不同，它们的结果也好了很多。即使当它们的结果没有好很多时，它们的结果也还可以。每一个错误，每一件事，每一个时刻都导致了这个完美的……甚至不是结局。听起来我好像在结尾，但这不是结局。它导致了这些完美的境况，我不会改变。有很多事情把我带到了这个地方，糟糕的男朋友，糟糕的成绩，非常大的友谊破裂，比如我是那个做错的人，我仍然为此感到内疚，还有糟糕的财务决定。让我告诉你。我做出了糟糕的财务选择。我会再做一次吗？不会。但如果我没有
make that bad choice, I would be any better off? Like, I actually can't. And so, the best thing I can say to myself is, well, that had to happen. There had to be some reason behind that to bring me to where I am. And there always is, I don't want to say a reason, but there, there always is this serendipity and this kind of invisible string that you will be able to connect through your life experiences that have brought you to where you are. So if you are in your early 20s, especially if you're 21 or younger, I get so many messages, it's just, there's just so much anxiety and so much fear and I just feel so much deep empathy for you because I remember how that felt so supremely and how it felt like nothing was ever going to make sense. I wanted somebody
做出那个糟糕的选择，我怎么能说我会过得更好呢？我真的不能。所以，我能对自己说的最好的话是，好吧，那必须发生。那背后一定有什么原因把我带到了我现在的位置。而且总是有，我不想说是一个原因，但总是有……总是有这种机缘巧合和这种无形的线，你可以通过你的生活经历将它们连接起来，把你带到你现在的位置。所以如果你20岁出头，特别是如果你21岁或更小，我收到了很多信息，就是……就是有太多的焦虑和太多的恐惧，我真的对你感到深深的同情，因为我记得那种感觉是多么强烈，以及那种感觉好像什么都不会有意义。我想要某个人
to tell me that my life was going to be okay. And here I am five, six years, I can't remember about five years, I guess, later down the line. And it's like a gift that only hindsight can give you. So keep pushing on. It's all going to be fine. Take what I say with you. it with a grain of salt. As I said, half the people said this, half the people said that when it came to grades, when it came to age gap relationships, when it came to marriage in your early 20s. So do what feels right. Know that all mistakes are in some ways a form of guidance and bring you to perhaps where you need to be. So that is all for today. That is the 10 things I would say, I would scream, I would give on a nice golden platter to my younger self.
告诉我我的生活会没事的。而我在这里，五年、六年，我不记得了，大概五年后，就像只有事后诸葛亮才能给你的礼物。所以继续前进吧。一切都会好起来的。带着我说的这些话，持保留态度。正如我所说，当谈到成绩、年龄差距关系、20岁出头结婚时，一半人这么说，一半人那么说。所以做你觉得对的事情。要知道，所有的错误在某种程度上都是一种指导，并把你带到你可能需要去的地方。所以今天就到这里。这就是我会说、我会尖叫、我会用一个漂亮的金色盘子送给年轻自己的10件事。
I want to hear yours. If there is anything in this episode that you felt I should have included or something that you really think people who are younger 21, 2219 need to know, leave a comment down below, especially if you are listening on Spotify. I'd love to hear from you. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast so you know when your episodes come out, or you can hit follow slash subscribe wherever you were listening. We also have a substack where I shared this full list so you can go and follow us over there. and a final reminder, if you haven't yet, please watch an episode on Netflix. It is one of the easiest ways to help out this podcast.
我想听听你们的。如果这一集里有什么你觉得我应该包括的内容，或者你真的认为那些比21岁、22岁、19岁更年轻的人需要知道的事情，请在下方留言，特别是如果你是在Spotify上收听的话。我很想听听你们的意见。确保你在Instagram上关注我们 @ThatPsychologyPodcast，这样你就知道什么时候出新集了，或者你可以在你收听的地方点击关注/订阅。我们还有一个Substack，我在那里分享了这个完整列表，所以你可以去那里关注我们。最后提醒一下，如果你还没有，请在Netflix上观看一集。这是帮助这个播客最简单的方法之一。
So if you've ever gotten even a tiny, tiny little bit of joy or comfort or, I don't know, factoid or assurance from this podcast, please go and watch an episode if you have Netflix. It really shows them that podcasts like this are important and it's a great way to help me out. I hope you enjoyed the episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Lisa, tell them about our new show. We have a new podcast. It's called Don't Lie to Me. I'm Lexi Youanu. We're two best friends, 22 years apart, but so close at heart. And I'm Lisa Di Giulio, the old one, which means we have wildly different references,
所以如果你曾经从这个播客中得到过哪怕一点点、一点点的快乐或安慰，或者，我不知道，事实或保证，请在你有Netflix的情况下观看一集。这真的向他们展示了像这样的播客很重要，这是帮助我的好方法。希望你喜欢这一集。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再谈。丽莎，告诉他们我们的新节目。我们有一个新播客。它叫《别对我撒谎》。我是莱克西·尤瓦诺。我们是两个最好的朋友，相差22岁，但心却贴得很近。我是丽莎·迪朱利奥，那个年长的人，这意味着我们有截然不同的参考系，
occasionally different opinions, and at this point in my 50s, I've lived it all. Now in my 30s, being the founder of new shoes, good taste, is. My Business. Listen on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Lacey Mosley, author, actor, stand-up comedian, creator, and host of Scam Goddess Podcasts, the True Crime Comedy Podcasts, all about robbery, fraud, and those who practice it. Each week, I bring on an amazing guest. Ooh, I scammed them. What? I can talk to you for an hour. You're a generational yapper, like me. That's why I had to make yapping a job. And now you can catch full episodes of my show on YouTube.
偶尔有不同的观点，而在我50多岁的现在，我已经经历了一切。现在我30多岁了，作为新鞋品牌的创始人，好品味是我的生意。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我是莱西·莫斯利，作家、演员、单口喜剧演员、创作者，也是《骗子女神》（Scam Goddess）播客的主持人，这是一个关于抢劫、欺诈以及那些实践它的人的真实犯罪喜剧播客。每周，我都会请来一位很棒的嘉宾。哦，我骗了他们。什么？我可以和你聊一个小时。你和我一样是个滔滔不绝的人。这就是为什么我必须把滔滔不绝变成一份工作。现在你可以在YouTube上观看我节目的完整剧集。
Start listening to Scam Goddess on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artist Podcast.
开始在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《骗子女神》。嗨，我是凯莉·布雷克曼。安吉尔·杰拉塔纳。杰里米·科尔汉。帕特里克·麦克唐纳。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》（Artists on Artists on Artists on Artist）播客的主持人。
The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks. on Halloween.
这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们，参加一个欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的小组讨论。我们有时也会过万圣节。教皇会打扮吗？他眨眼。在万圣节。
It's right up next on the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists
就在麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从来没见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》
every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, it's Alec Baldwin. This season on my podcast, here's the thing. I talk to actor Stephen Root. I'm a people watcher. You see that guy going down to the dingo.
每周四在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。嘿，我是亚历克·鲍德温。本季在我的播客上，《这就是事实》。我采访了演员斯蒂芬·鲁特。我是一个观察者。你看到那个人走在街上，
Yeah, I can use that. And open. glue co-founder Alia Mohammed. I love staying on top of what is going on in our city, what is on renter's minds, and taking all of that knowledge to build a platform that hopefully is going to make New York City better in the long run. Listen to Here's the Thing on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的，我可以利用这一点。还有Open Igloo联合创始人阿莉亚·穆罕默德。我喜欢掌握我们城市正在发生的事情，租客们在想什么，并利用所有这些知识建立一个平台，希望从长远来看能让纽约市变得更好。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《这就是事实》。
What up, y'all. This your main man, Memphis Bleak right here. Host of that rock solid podcast. And each week, we bring in you exclusive looks inside music. everything happening inside the culture. Some of the best conversations were the biggest names in the game. You had a little bit more pressure to be good. And they didn't care if you was a girl.
大家好。我是你们的老朋友，孟菲斯·布里克。那个《坚如磐石》（Rock Solid）播客的主持人。每周，我们都会带给你音乐内部的独家视角，文化中发生的一切。游戏中最响亮的名字之间进行的一些最好的对话。你会有更大的压力去表现出色。而且他们不在乎你是不是个女孩。
Like, you wasn't getting no points. If you're not trash, you better be not just good. You better be great. Listen to Rock Solid on Black Effect Podcast Network, iHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you string podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就像，你得不到任何分数。如果你不是垃圾，你最好不仅是好。你最好是伟大。在Black Effect播客网络、iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《坚如磐石》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真实。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。